bleibt mir von der pelle
es ist meine haut es ist keine außenhaut
aus blech und stahl die man über die
versicherung ersetzen kann
denn es sind immer gleich meine knochen
christian storm weg macht eigentlich
alles auf zwei rädern seine tochter alma
meist mit im gepäck
im alltag fühlt er sich aber oft
ausgebremst von rücksichtslosen
autofahrern
heute ist er mit seinem frust nicht
alleine
einmal im monat treffen sich berliner
radfahrer zum gemeinsamen protest der
soll auch spaß machen aber ihr anliegen
ist erbt
naja
sie wollen aufmerksam machen auf
schlechte oder fehlende radwege und auf
gefahren im verkehr
ja
ein böser radler autofahrer
feindbild vieler autofahrer jetzt die
sogenannte kritik
ich bin das schalten von deutschland
dass die logos erlauben
medwedew
legal ist das ganze aber denn bei mehr
als 16 radfahrern dürfen laut
straßenverkehrsordnung alle in einem zug
über die kreuzung bei rund 2000
teilnehmern kann das leben dauern
eine offizielle demo ist die critical
mass nicht
es gibt bewusst keinen veranstalter die
verabredung findet über facebook statt
auch die route ist spontan zufällig nur
zu verfolgen über die eigene app kritik
seit zwei stunden ist die gruppe jetzt
schon unterwegs manche fahren die ganze
nacht einfach schön einmal im monat ist
quasi ein bisschen lebensraum in der
stadt zurückzuholen wird für die autos
gemacht die haben zweifelsfrei spuren
und wir nicht
wir warten auf der busspur wo die autos
wieso nicht fahren dürfen wurden die
ganze zeit wirkt jede vorbeifahren auto
anruf bei trainern den weg waren soll
eigentlich ein friedlicher protest sein
aber die stimmung ist christian dieses
mal zu geladen
er zieht griechen seine tochter erst mal
aus dem verkehr
ich denke ich bleib nicht stehen guck
mal wo die lang fahren und dann
entscheiden wir spontan ob wir da noch
mal einsteigen oder nicht oder aber der
harte kern fährt weiter über die roten
ampeln der nacht als albtraum für die
autofahrer